hey everybody this is just a really
quick intro bit before we get into the
bulk of this video this past weekend I
was at terrific on in Connecticut and I
went with my partner Liz and we were
there all three days we went to panels
we saw cosplay we did cosplay ourselves
we bought stuff and this is what I've
put together it's kind of a little recap
of the whole thing this is just kind of
a little clips and moments and
highlights and cool stuff if you want a
more complete rundown of what it was
like and what we you know things that
went on at the panels and whatnot
there'll also be a podcast out on the
same day this gets released on the
council of geeks podcast feed I'll put a
link down in the description and this is
and also beep forgivingly me this is my
first time going to aconitine stuff with
the intent of getting content out of it
so I'm pretty happy with what I got but
you know a bit of a learning curve bear
with me here
but let's go so we are here we are
checked in 29th floor view of the river
and somewhere out there is the
convention center or possibly out the
other side I don't know we haven't found
it yet well figure out though
well we're reasonably well educated
human beings eventually we'll find it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
groovy
alright so day two I'm just slithering
it up today and liz has opted to go for
Luna so much so we're headed back to
head up the floor probably gonna end up
spending more money today oh yeah we
gotta figure out what panels are going
on and yeah it's been fun already and
looking forward to more but
[Music]
[Applause]
okay so that's day two done we just got
out from seeing from seeing John
Barrowman and Liz photo photobombing
we'll just get well just get the hat
this is so much fun and I am loving the
absolute heck out of this
oh man is a good time
so last day at terrific on going Star
Wars I'm bringing back Darth snow and we
have Liz doing her lieutenant onyx and
wrapping up with Krispy Kreme and then
we've got the last day on the floor
[Laughter]
[Music]
to get on you say your piece if you get
off and if in the process of doing that
you slip on a banana peel what happens
is what our team Goodwyn always says
that they've got 30 days to fix it if
you're doing a 50 if you cross over
extending over six months and 14 titles
if you slip on the banana peel with the
third issue you are in a awkward
situation and I can fix it
you've gotta fix it because otherwise
you may end up with readers who say I'm
going back to you know reading introns
[Music]
I noticed a phenomenon when I went and I
was asked to speak several commuters
before and after and everybody here
knows a joke about black people can't be
quiet the movie the Black Panther movie
nobody who's fun they were all laughing
at the same time they were all talking
at the same time you know stomping their
feet and I've been moving since I was a
kid 80 when I was about your age when I
first started going to movies and we and
walkers but but I've never been to a
theater in my entire life with everybody
the theater was on the same please okay
and the Black Panthers obviously about
Africans but that didn't stop you from
showing up the character's been around
for 30 years and it's just been new
blood pumped into who the characters
every new writer it's better than face
to it they put something into it the
times where he was like fellow and no
one really knows
pay attention to which happens in the
universe but here he is taking equal
position with the other superheroes
that's what I saw
[Music]
[Music]
I
[Applause]
okay so we're done we're now in the car
because we had to check out of the hotel
um but we wrapped up for today we got to
see the costume contest some of which
the footage of which folks will have
seen the Iron Giant which one was
incredible and this has been this has
been a really great trip and I want to
thank you for coming with me I think I I
think I would have enjoyed this for
growth's I think I enjoyed it a lot more
for having you with me and and i wanna i
want to thank my patreon supporters
which I kind of do every time anyways
but I really need to do it this time
because I I couldn't they they got me
here I could not have afforded to come
here without having hit the level of
page here on support that I have and so
that super amazing also plug for that
because there's other amazing stuff I'd
love to do to that additional support
would help but and even if you don't
support on the patreon if you're just
watching this if you share it if you
like it if you comment whatever you do
whatever interact level of interaction
you have folks you're the council I just
run the meetings if I'm lucky I get to
do it with this one and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]